là est le problème
non mais c'est toujours [ __ ] à poil et
tenait donc voilà je suis batman c'est
la fin d'un projet de mon stage dans ma
vie non mais j'avoue un match plutôt pas
mal
tu n'auras jamais merci pour la veste
mon travail mais faire victimiser
bonjour j'adore le bond à ipsca
moustache du club bassin plutôt bon
moment
lourd on va aller tourner dans une boîte
de nuit en premier de paris donc on est
le mario montagnard au pas que tu vois
le rapport on voyagera plus ok trad dans
avec le maître hugo avec des cordes
autour bloqué en prison tu vois bon
c'est une bonne idée hockey et ferme ta
gueule là je vais je vais pécho todd aka
cyprien doivent savoir que cyprien des
shows la ferme jérôme et pas longtemps
comparé sur une homosexualité général
chef scout moi ça me gêne pas je suis
plutôt d'ailleurs excité
al'approche de ce moment oui on attend
le fait qu'il devient porte bien non
c'est parce que tu crois
dédicace est fournie babe si je vais ou
d'otis tu vas voir si j'ai des caries
quand j'écoute durable j'écoute booba
fit ainsi qu'à richesse
arrivé à caen non j'ai plus jeunes aux
pieds ok c'est reparti je vous ai plein
de monde oui excuse moi maintenant de
bien évidemment parle de basket je parle
de nbi y est je fais le 110 mètres de
110 m haies je vais à l'école donc je
suis en école vieille autour de mon cou
j'ai un col et savoir je pense qu'il va
être assez cool acea
c'est un gay enfin c'est différent des
autres merci normal on est au vip room
des fois quand je démarre sa fait vroum
vroum
[Musique]
c'est par la casse est bien parti je
suis à la galipotte s'approchant le sol
falloir investir sa pas au plaisir
d'être là mais je t'éclate qui comme on
tape five c'est peut-être que c'était
pas top ce que je fais ça je veux c'est
ce que suggère seulement une en gardant
galère de 10,2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]